[Musique]
française
français dimanche prochain en élisant le
chef de l'État
vous aurez à désigner le
français que vous estimez en
conscience le plus digne et le plus
capable de représenter la France et de
garantir son
destin car c'est de cela qu'il
s'agit le président de la République ne
saurait être en effet confondu avec
aucune
fraction il doit tenir à la Nation toute
entière exprimer et
servir le seul intérêt général c'est à
ce
titre et c'est à cause de cela que je
demande votre
confiance cinq
oppositions vous présente CIN
candidats vous les avez tous entendus
vous les avez tous
reconnu leur voix dénigrante surtous les
sujet leurs promesses distribuées à
toutes les
catégories leurs appels à l'effacement
international de la France ce sont les
voies les promesses les appels des
anciens partis tendant quoi qu'il puisse
prétendre à retrouver le régime d'entant
aussi le seul point sur lequel s'accorde
leur passion c'est mon
départ mais ce n'est pas
assez car leur contradiction mutuelle
leurs clientèles
inconciliables
leurs engagements dans tous les
sens montrent à
l'évidence que l'accession de l'un
quelconque d'entre eux au poste
suprême marquerait
infailliblement le retour à l'odieuse
confusion où se traînait nagerre l'État
pour le malheur de la
France or ces
jeuxlà nous ont coûté assez cher pour
que nous ayons
appris que dans le monde
difficile et dangereux où nous
vivons rien de valable ne peut être
accompli sans l'adhésion profonde de la
nation à ce qui lui est commun et
essentiel et bien vous le savez c'est
cela que les événements m'ont amené à
représenter à travers toutes les
tempêtes et par-dessus tous les
intérêts et c'est au nom de
cela que vous m'avez donné votre
appui pourquoi
faire pendant la guerre après le
désastre où le régime des partis avait
conduit notre pays divisé par eux et
privé par eux des armes
nécessair la résistance qui aboutit à la
victoire lors de la
libération un ensemble sans précédent de
réforme comme par
exemple la sécurité sociale les
allocations familiales les
nationalisations les comités
d'entreprise le statut du fermage le
droit de vote aux femmes et
cetera réforme qui en nous évitant de
très graves
bouleversements remplacèrent le mauvais
système d laisser faire laisser
passer réformes auxquelles après mon
départ le régime des parti se
débattant dans
l'impuissance
n'a rien
ajoué et puis depuis 7 ans après son
effondrement devant laabîme de la guerre
civile et devant l' ance de la faillite
économique et monétaire commenceça la
marche en
avant par l'adoption d'institutions
stables et
efficaces la coopération remplaçant la
colonisation le développement planifié
au profit de tous les
Français de notre
économie de notre équipement de notre
enseignement de nos capacités
scientifiques technique bref l'impulsion
dans tous les champs d'action ouvert à
nos forces vives au
dehors par une politique d'indépendance
et
d'équilibre l'action menée partout en
faveur de la
paix notamment en Asie où sévite une
absurde guerre l'effort entrepris pour
recoudre notre continent
déchiré du part en poursuivant
l'organisation de l'Europe occidentale
et l'autre part en nouant avec les pays
de l'Est des rapports
multipliés la présence l'influence la
culture française
s'affermissant dans toutes les parties
de la terre est-ce parfait est-ce
complet bien sûr que
non puisqu'il s'agit d'une œuvre humaine
mais cette œuvre là qui s'appelle le
salut et puis le début de la rénovation
peut bien être
décriée par les champions de la
décadence
elle n'en est pas moins évidente et
reconnu du monde
entier cependant il faut qu'elle se
développe et s'élargisse davantage
encore
oui la République
nouvelle veut que le peuple lui
donne
demain plus tard et
toujours une tête qui en souhait
une et que l'homme ainsi mandaté pour
répondre du destin notamment dans les
jours
graves porte lui-même ses responsabilité
oui la République nouvelle veut que
notre notre pays continue d'avancer dans
la
prospérité suivant ce que prévoit la loi
du
plan de telle sorte que les revenus de
tous les Français
s'accroissent
avec le produit
nationale sur la base d'une économie
concurrente avec celle de tous les
autres d'une monnaie
inébranlable et de budget
équilibré oui la France
nouvelle comme la République
nouvelle veul que tout en restant allié
de nos alliés et amis de nos amis
elle ne pratique
plus cette
subordination à l'égard de l'un
de qui serait indigne
d'elle et qui pourrait
automatiquement dans certains cas les
jeter dans un conflit qu'elle n'aurait
pas voulu
oui la République nouvelle veut doter la
France d'un armement
nucléaire parce que quatre autres état
en ont
un parce que tout le monde
sachant qu'elle ne menace personne
il se trouve qu'un pareil instrument rev
pour sa
défense un caractère de dissuasion
incomparable par rapport au système
d'autrefois parce qu'il nous coûte pas
plus cher et qui nous a permis de
diminuer de moitié la durée du service
militaire enfin parce qu'à notre époque
atomique
électronique
spatial nous ne devons pas priver la
recherche la science la technique
l'industrie française de tout ce
qu'elles peuvent tirer et de tout ce
qu'elles tireront pour leur progrès et
pour leur activité de cette nécessaire
entreprise
oui la République
nouvelle qui a déployé pour l'Union de
l'Europe
occidentale de grands constants efforts
en partie couronné de succès veut que
l'édifice
s'achève dans des conditions équitaable
et
raisonnable que l'agriculture française
entre dans le marché commun
effectivement et sans que par la suite
quelques commission d supranationale ou
quelques vote à la
majorité puisse remettre tout en cause
que si un jour il s'agit de bâtir une
organisation politique des
6 la France par les fait de cette même
procédure ne risque pas d'être entraîné
sur notre
continent dans une action
dangereuse et qu'elle n'approuverit
pas tout
cela
fait de telle sorte que jamais ne soit
étouffer aucune de nos
libertés cela se
fait
en conjuguant et non pas en
opposant le courant du
mouvement qui porte au changements et
aux
réformes et le courant de l'ordre
qui tient à la tradition et à la
règle cela se
fait grâce aux
appels que j'ai main de fois adressé
franchement et
directement à chacune à chacun de vous
dimanche ce sera le
cas puisqu'il va
dépendre de vous toutes et de vous
tous que je poursuive ou non ma
mission le 5 décembre si vous le
voulez la République nouvelle sera
définitivement
établie alors elle prendra le
départ pour une autre
étape d'autant plus ardante et
féconde il
s'agit que pendant le
temps où je resterai à sa tête elle
redouble son
effort nationale et
mondial qu'après moi
elle
demeure normalement et suivant sa ligne
enfin qu'au long de l'avenir
elle procure à notre pays ce qu'elle lui
assure aujourd'hui
l'indépendance le progrès la
paix française
français continuons la France vive la
République vive la
France
vous venez d'assister à une émission de
la campagne pour l'élection du Président
de la
République